Ashley Madison the website for married
people who want to have secret affairs
was hacked
yesterday the hackers posted the names
and emails of Ashley Madison's 40
million users so as you can imagine
today there are a lot of people eager to
explain why their names showed up in the
Ashley Madison database we talked to a
few take a look my niece Ashley goes to
University of Wisconsin in Madison I was
trying to send her a facebook I have an
Ashley Madison brand laptop I thought I
had to login to their website to turn it
off I know what it was it was the day I
caught my cat walking across my keyboard
she must have entered all my personal
information someone clearly assumed my
identity set up a fake account and then
placed me in bed with this woman that
isn't my wife
I know why my name was on there I'm in a
loveless marriage and I created a
profile so I could have an affair first
of all you can't be sure it's me a lot
of people had the name qualities
defective dolls how did I end up on
Ashley madison.com you know what
actually it's kind of a funny story
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]